what's going on uh if you are not
acquiring customers
every single week week in week out then
this
is for you all right so fundamentally
two ways you can well there's six ways
you can search for clients but two that
i want to talk about today
is going to be outbound and inbound all
right so outbound being like you're
actively reaching out to people and
getting a certain small percentage to
respond
and the other version of that is paid
ads
which is fundamentally again outbound
you're displaying stuff it's just you're
paying a platform to have the eyeball
rather than doing the manual work to get
the eyeball
but the result is more or less the same
a certain percentage like one percent
click from the ad
and then they go through the process
whereas when you're doing outbound you
have one percent that might respond to
your
outbound response and then it comes
inbound right so
what i want to talk about here is the
number one thing that i see people that
mess this up
is that they do insufficient volume
and so what i want to do is give you a
rule of thumb that i'm coining the rule
of 100 all right and
what it basically states and i'm i
haven't heard this from anyone so i'm
i'm claiming it as my own all right is
that if you do a hundred of something
every day
you'll likely get better at it and
you'll likely be doing enough that you
will be able to start seeing an outcome
so in theory if you were like the
biggest master of all time you would
need to do
less volume to get the same outcome if i
was the best paid
advertiser of all time then i wouldn't
need to do a ton of paid advertising
to get a lot of sales right right to the
same degree if i was the best cold
caller in existence
i would need to do far fewer calls in
order to generate the outcome they're
looking for
more sales right but here's the twist
how do you think you become
the best paid advertiser of all time how
do you think you become the best
cold outbound cold messenger cold email
or cold caller
of all time volume and so
the volume begets the skill but the
thing is as you get better at something
you like doing it more
and so this is actually a circle that
continues to reinforce itself
and the thing is is that most people do
not start with the first thing in high
enough
quantity they do not do sufficient
volume
which is why i'm introducing the rule of
100. and so basically it states that if
you are not
acquiring like right now if you're not
acquiring customers
then you're not doing the rule of 100.
it's very simple if you're not spending
100
per day on advertising
or doing a hundred reach outs
per day then how do you expect to grow
right and i'm saying this you can add
zeros you can remove zeros whatever but
the idea is that at a base level and
this is per person this is per
per human being right that you have
that's working
if you are not doing this then you're
not going to grow
right and so most people do outbound and
they do it one time a week or one time
every two weeks when they feel motivated
they don't do it every day to the same
degree they're doing uh
paid ads and they're like well i spent
you know i spent 100 bucks
it's like so what you got to spend 100
every day right and then what's going to
happen is you're going to suck in the
beginning and you hope
you can break even and then over time
the skill
will improve and then you will get more
back from your volume
right but everyone wants to have a a
huge skill
and do low volume to get their outcome
but the reality is that to generate the
skill you have to have the volume
and then in so doing you do more volume
times the skill and the skill gets
better
and then the outcome continues to
increase and so right now
if you're not doing 100 outreaches a day
in your business where you're not
spending 100
a day on ads how are you going to get
clients
like what's the plan like how like like
how is this working and so
one of the number one things is like
when someone's reaching out to me and
they're like man i wish i could get more
clients i'm like well are you doing
either of these
first question and if they're not then
it's like well then
don't pass go do one of these two pick
one it doesn't really matter
the thing is is that if it's just you
running in your business then this is
going to be the cheapest thing to do
because it's just selling your time
right in the beginning and you'll be
able to do this and then you can teach
another person
and then another person and then another
person how to continue to do this
because you will then have the skill
that you can drop into their brains
and so that they can replicate the same
results you will and reality is
they're not going to replicate the same
result they'll probably do it half as
well or a third as well
but if you can still get uh you know
thirty to one
ten to one returns on on the reach out
efforts that you're doing then you can
stand to have a
you know fifty percent as effective
person but have ten people doing it
right at the end of the day most people
especially when you're in the earlier
parts of the business the people you
hire aren't going to be better than you
are
at these things but 10 of them
will be better than you are at those
things and that was one of the biggest
jumps i had to take is that
sometimes you have to take a short step
back when you go from you not selling to
somebody else selling
right but you can quickly go from one
person to three people to five people
selling because you
are no longer the bottleneck of the
constraint all right and so just
recognizing that
and using the rule of 100 as a rule of
thumb for any of the
any of the acquisition efforts that you
were doing i guarantee you
uh will will serve you in your life and
so it's like if you have not spent a
hundred dollars every day
or if you have not done 100 reach outs
every day and you are struggling
to get clients then do that first and
then
keep doing it not one day do it every
day for 90 days
right do it every day for 90 days and i
guarantee you you will have customers by
the end of that process
all right so anyways lots of love put
those value before you um
if you did enjoy this drop a like drop a
comment and um
i'll see you guys soon bye